hallo
und zwar wenn meine erste oktobers neues
album sein kann aber auch dass durch den
teufelskreis ist oder ob das noch mehr
in richtung der alten müssen meine
zweite frage wäre ob es ein junge oder
ein
mädchen dies auch auf jeden fall gut up
to date was die musik angeht schönen
gruß an dich
jbg 2 ist auf jeden fall ein großes
thema ich denke mal in naher zukunft
wenn zu wenn sie denn jetzt noch gut
läuft wird es auf jeden fall stattfinden
ich denke mal
also ich bin auf keinen fall abgeneigt
kollege auch nicht und deswegen denke
ich auf jeden fall dass es schon noch
zustande kommen wird man muss sich halt
nur ein bisschen gedulden
ansonsten
ja mein album hieß es es ist
zur hälfte der alte oder was heißt der
alte farid bang zur hälfte ist es halt
die sind es halt der typische farid bang
und zur anderen hälfte ist es dann
natürlich auch wissen dass es
mit mit themenvielfalt da irgendwie drin
vorkommt sprich wie bei teufelskreis des
anfangs mensch der ist auch sehr sehr
schöner song ist auch kann ich jedem nur
empfehlen da mal reinzuhören ist auf
jeden fall geradezu dieser situation zu
dieser diskussions debatte zwischen
ausländern und deutschen ist das auf
jeden fall eine sache die beide seiten
vertritt nun auch sehr interessant ist
für alle leute also es lohnt sich auf
jeden fall mal reinzuhören ich denke mal
es ist kein fehler und da ist auf jeden
fall musik didier und auch vielen
anderen leuten spaß bereiten wird